[ Music ]
JEAN-FRANCOIS BILODEAU:
Picture this,
a sensitive file leaves your
organization, nobody realizes it
until a week later, and now
you're piecing together what
happened with incomplete
evidence and a ticking clock.
In security operation
those moments are exactly
when you need fast answer
what data was exposed,
who touched it, and
what to do next.
Let me introduce you to a
session where we'll learn how
to tackle these real-world
scenarios using Microsoft
Purview and connected
investigation tool.
Hello, and welcome, we're
glad you've joined us.
I am Jean-Francois Bilodeau, a
Microsoft Technical Trainer.
In this session, let's
explore Learning Path 3,
Mitigate Threat Using
Microsoft Purview.
Together we'll walk through how
security operation analysts can
support compliance and
investigation workflow,
starting with data loss
prevention alerts,
moving into insider
risk management,
and then using eDiscovery
and Auditing to investigate,
validate, and export
the evidence you need.
So let's get started
with this session.
Here we set the stage
for the bigger mission,
defending against cyberthreats
using Microsoft Security
Operations platform.
The goal isn't just
to detect threats,
it's to investigate
them efficiently,
connect security signals
together, compliance, evidence,
and take action with confidence
when data or users are at risk.
Let's take a look at
what we'll cover.
We'll begin with Microsoft
Purview Compliance Solution,
then move into investigating
and remediating compromised
entities identified
by Microsoft Purview data
loss prevention policies.
From there, we'll explore
how to investigate
and remediate insider
risk threat identified
by Microsoft Purview policies.
Next we'll shift
into investigation techniques
using Microsoft Purview
eDiscovery Content Search.
And then we'll finish
with investigation using
Microsoft Purview Audit,
first Audit Standard, then
we'll move into Audit Premium.
Here we transition
into Microsoft Purview
Compliance Solutions
capabilities, designed to help
organizations protect sensitive
information, meet
regulatory obligations,
and investigate issues
when something goes wrong.
For security operation
analysts, like us,
the key is understanding how
these tools complement security
detection with compliance-grade
evidence and control.
To access these
compliance capabilities,
you'll work with the
Microsoft Purview portal
at purview.microsoft.com.
From this centralized portal,
you can navigate into areas
like data loss prevention,
insider risk management,
eDiscovery, and Audit, each one
supporting a different part
of the investigation and
response life cycle.
Let's clarify how security
operation analysts often partner
with compliance and
eDiscovery administrators.
One major area is eDiscovery,
especially "Content Search,"
which supports finding
and exporting relevant
electronic information
that may be needed as evidence
in legal or in internal cases.
Another key area is auditing.
Microsoft Purview auditing
solutions provides an integrated
way to capture and review user
and administrator activity,
helping organizations
respond to security events,
support forensic investigations,
and run internal investigations.
We also have
information protection
where data loss prevention, DLP,
helps organizations
prevent users
from inappropriately sharing
sensitive information
such as financial data,
proprietary data,
credit card numbers,
health records,
or Social Security numbers.
And finally, insider risk
management correlates a variety
of signals to identify
potential malicious
or inadvertent insider risk,
like intellectual property
theft, data leakage,
or security violations
so teams can detect
and contain issues
before they grow.
Now we shift into first
investigation module,
using Microsoft Purview
DLP policies to identify,
compromise entities, and then
remediate the situation.
The key theme is
turning a DLP signal,
like sensitive data exposure,
into a clear investigation path
and actionable next steps.
After completing this
module, you should be able
to do three things: first,
describe the key data
loss prevention component
in Microsoft Purview, second,
investigate DLP alerts directly
in the Microsoft Purview
compliance center, and finally,
investigate DLP alerts
in Microsoft Defender
for Cloud Apps, which
is especially useful
when you're looking at
cloud app activities
and file-related controls.
With a DLP policy, you can
identify sensitive information
and prevent the accidental
sharing of that information.
You can also monitor and protect
sensitive content directly
into desktop versions of
Excel, PowerPoint, and Word,
so protection isn't
limited to the web.
Another important benefit is
agitation without disruption.
DLP can help users learn how
to stay compliant while
keeping their workflow moving.
And from the investigation
site, you can view DLP alerts
and reports that show content
matching your organization's DLP
policy, giving you
evidence you can act on.
To understand how those
alerts are generated,
it helps to know the core
components involved:
sensitive information
type, sensitivity labels,
and the data loss prevention
policy itself, and finally,
in Cloud Apps scenarios,
a Defender for Cloud
Apps file policy.
Here we look at investigating
DLP alerts directly
into Microsoft Purview.
When an alert is triggered,
you can review what content
matched the policy,
which location it occurred
in, which user was involved,
and what actions were taken,
so it can quickly determine
whether this was an accident,
a risky pattern, or a
potential compromise
that needs escalation.
Next, let's take a look
at investigating DLP alerts
inside Microsoft Defender XDR.
A practical approach is to
create and apply an alert filter
where the category is set
to "data loss prevention".
This helps you quickly pivot
from the broader incident queue
into the subset of alert tied
to a sensitive data exposure.
And it's worth remembering
that Defender for Cloud Apps
and Cloud Apps alerts
are consolidated
into Microsoft Defender XDR.
So this becomes a
central place to triage
and correlate Cloud Apps related
DLP activities alongside other
security signals.
Now we move from
accidental data exposure
into a different category
of risk, insider risk.
Here the objective
is to investigate
and remediate threats identified
by Microsoft Purview
insider risk policy,
whether the behavior is
malicious, negligent,
or simply high risk in context.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to explain how insider
risk management
in Microsoft Purview
helps prevent, detect,
and contain internal
risks in an organization.
You'll also be able to describe
the built-in predefined policy
templates, list the prerequisite
that must be met before you can
create insider risk policies,
and explain the kind
of action you can take
when you're working an
insider risk management case.
Insider risk
management is designed
to help you address the
type of risk and violations
that can come from
within the organization.
That can include intentional
misuse, like data theft,
or unintentional actions,
like accidental leaks
or policy violations.
The value here is correlation.
Instead of looking one
isolated incident,
insider risk management
brings signals together
to highlight patterns that
deserve investigation.
Here we walk through the
workflow used by Microsoft 365,
to identify and resolve
internal risk activities
and compliance issues with
insider risk management.
The workflow focuses on moving
from signals to indicator
into policy detection, then
into triage and investigation,
and finally, into taking
appropriate action
to resolve the risk while
aligning to privacy
and compliance expectations.
Managing insider
risk policies starts
with choosing the
right policy template.
Common templates include
departing employees data theft,
data leaks, and currently
preview security policy
violations, health record
misuse, and risky browser usage.
Once you select a template, you
can configure policy settings
such as privacy indicators,
the timeframe the
policy should evaluate,
and the intelligent detection
used to identify risky behavior
with the right balance of
visibility and privacy.
Now let's turn to eDiscovery,
specifically how to search
for content using
Microsoft Purview.
This capability is critical when
an investigation requires you
to find, preserve, and
potentially export content
across Microsoft 365 services in
a way that supports compliant
and legal defensibility.
In this module, the learning
objectives are straightforward.
You'll learn how to assign the
role and permission required
to access Microsoft Purview
eDiscovery, how to create
and manage keys used to
run eDiscovery searches,
how to define search scope and
build queries using conditions,
keywords, and Copilot-generated
prompts, and finally,
how to run searches and validate
results using statistics
or random samples.
Let's define what eDiscovery is
and how it compares
to Content Search.
eDiscovery is a tool in the
Microsoft Purview portal
that lets you
search for content,
place hold, and export content.
Access is limited to users who
have assigned the right role,
typically eDiscovery managers
or eDiscovery administrators
and licensing impacts
which feature you can use
with Core eDiscovery
included in E3 and E5.
You'll use eDiscovery for
internal investigation
like HR cases, or suspected
data misuse, as well as legal
and regulatory requests, data
subject rights requests,
and incident responses
or breach reviews.
The big idea is that
eDiscovery helps security
and compliance teams
find, preserve,
and export content during
investigations, legal inquiries,
or incident responses.
It's also important to
use eDiscovery as more
than a simple search feature.
While Content Search can
retrieve data quickly,
it doesn't provide the same
auditability and access control
that eDiscovery provides.
eDiscovery, on the other
hand, is designed for secure,
auditable searches
tied to a formal case
with role-based permission.
On to licensing side.
Core eDiscovery is available in
E5, and advanced eDiscovery,
often referred to as
"Premium," adds capability
like custodian holds,
legal hold notifications,
and built-in review sets.
Even if you're not
using the premium tier,
understanding the difference
helps you assess what your
environment can support.
A helpful way to internalize
this is to think
through a real-world
investigation,
like a phishing attack
or an insider leak,
where you create a
case, run a search,
and export results for review.
Before you can use
eDiscovery access,
you have to explicitly assign
to ensure investigation
remains secure and auditable.
The required roles are
typically eDiscovery managers
who can create and manage
cases, search and export,
and eDiscovery administrators
who have all the manager
permissions plus the ability
to manage role assignments
and control settings.
To assign these roles, you go to
the Microsoft Purview portal,
then you navigate to
"Settings," "Roles and Scope,"
and "Role Groups," and add users
to the appropriate role group.
To confirm access,
you can navigate
into eDiscovery in the portal.
If the user has the
correct role and license,
the "Create Case"
page should appear.
A key operational point is that
access is scoped intentionally.
Even if someone has
an eDiscovery tool,
they may only see their
case they're a member of,
which supports least
privileged access
and keeps unrelated
investigation separated.
This also helps with common
troubleshooting during
hands-on work.
If someone can't see
anything, it's usually
because they're missing
either the role assignment
or the case membership.
In Microsoft Purview eDiscovery,
every search is
created within a case.
The case acts as a secure
auditable workspace
for managing investigation.
That requirement matters because
it enforces access control,
keeps a consistent
investigation structure,
and ensures every action,
searching, accessing, exporting,
is logged in the
context of the case.
Only members of a case can
access it, even if they're
on an eDiscovery role, and when
somebody else creates the case,
they're automatically
added as a member.
To create a search, you go to
the eDiscovery open cases,
and then select "Create Search".
You provide the case name
and the search name,
and in a single step, Purview
creates both the case
and the search.
This case may structure
is what makes eDiscovery
legally defensible.
It provides a container where
you investigate diligence,
and data integrity
can be demonstrated
if the result ever needs
to stand up to scrutiny.
Now, let's walk through
conducting a search.
The purpose is to locate content
across Microsoft 365
services that's relevant
to a security incident,
a regulatory request,
or an internal investigation.
You start by defining the
criteria in your search,
set the filter using keyword or
conditions such as date, sender,
or content type, then you select
your data source, user, groups,
site, or even broader
tenant-wide sources,
depending on whether you want
to narrow the scope
or cast a wider net.
Next, you build a query logic.
You can use the
condition builder
if you prefer guided experience,
write KQL for more advanced
filtering, or where possible,
try Copilot or "Search by
File" in Purview to generate
or accelerate the search logic.
After you've run the search,
you review settings,
reusing statistics,
how many items match,
or a sample to validate
relevance before you explore.
From there, you refine
and rerun as needed.
A practical best practice is
to avoid scoping too broadly
at the start, because that
creates review overload.
Instead, start small,
validate, and then expand only
when the evidence tells you to.
Once you have the right result,
the next step is exporting
them along with metadata.
For investigation
documentation, legal review,
or external handoff,
you start an export
by selecting a completed
search of the search step
and choosing what to explore,
such as index items,
partially indexed items, or
both, then you configure option
for workload like OneDrive,
SharePoint, Exchange, Teams.
For example, whether to
include version history,
include threaded messages,
or cloud attachments,
you can chose the output format,
you want to use PST or MSG along
with a folder structure
and friendly naming.
As the export runs,
you track status
and detail in process manager.
When it's ready, you go
to the "Export" tab,
review the export overview,
and download the package
along with reports.
This step matters for
a chain of custody.
Export packages can include
original format and metadata,
and they're typically
delivered as secure packages
with manifest and logs.
Hashes and export identifiers
help demonstrate integrity,
showing the data hasn't been
modified, while secure,
time-limited download links
helps protect the export
during transfer.
Now we move into Microsoft
Purview Audit, which is all
about understanding activities
across Microsoft 365,
who did what, when, and where.
Audit data becomes critical
evidence for incident response,
compliance, verification,
and deeper investigation
where you need a
reliable activity trail.
In this module, you'll learn
how to identify the difference
between Microsoft Purview Audit
Standard and Audit Premium,
configure Microsoft
Purview Audit
for optimate log management
and perform audit
to assess compliant
and security measures.
You'll also learn how to analyze
irregular access patterns using
advanced tool available in
Audit Premium and PowerShell,
and how strategic data
management supports
regulatory compliance.
Microsoft Purview Audit helps
organization understand how
Microsoft 365 is being used
by capturing users
and admin activity.
That visibility supports
security investigation,
compliance requirement, and
operational transparency.
Audit Standard is
enabled by default,
providing 180-day log
retention that can be accessed
through the portal,
PowerShell, and API,
and supports exporting
results in CSV.
Audit Premium extends
those capabilities
with custom retention policies,
a default one-year retention
for core services, intelligence
insights into activity patterns,
and higher API bandwidth
for advanced integrations.
Together, these options give
organization flexibility
for day-to-day needs as well
as longer-term investigation
and regulatory requirements.
To put that in context,
Audit Standard is ideal
for general visibility, tracking
basic activities like sign-in,
file modification,
or sharing events.
Audit Premium, on
the other hand,
is where you get forensic
depth for longer-term
or higher-risk investigation,
including scenarios
where you need to know whether
a sensitive message was
actually accessed.
It's also important to remember
that Premium capabilities depend
on licensing, such as Microsoft
365 E5, or E5 Compliance,
or an equivalent add-on.
So you only see these features
if your environment
is entitled to them.
Now let's take a look at
configuration and management.
If auditing isn't already
enabled, you can turn it
on through the Purview
portal or by running the
"Set-AdminAuditLogConfig"
cmdlet in PowerShell.
You also need to
verify licensing.
Audit Standard is included
in Microsoft 365 E3 and E5,
as well as F1 and F3, and in
Office 365 E1, E3, and E5.
Audit Premium requires
Microsoft 365 E5,
E5 Compliance, or
relevant add-on.
Finally, role determines who
can work with audit logs.
An audit reader can
search and export log,
while an audit manager
can search and explore
but also manage audit settings.
Even if someone is
a global admin,
they still need the
right role assignment
in Purview to access logs.
A good investigation habit is to
confirm Audit is enabled early,
because if logging wasn't
on, then there may be no way
to have an activity
trail to follow.
Audit Standard provides the
tool needed to search, manage,
and analyze activity
across Microsoft 365,
helping organizations
respond to incidents
and meet compliance
requirements.
You can search audit log using
the Microsoft Purview portal
or "Vsurge-unifiedauditlog"
cmdlet.
As you search, you filter
by activity type, user,
file or site, date
range, workload,
and you can export
results or access logs
through an API for automation.
As a result comes in, you
can monitor job progress,
drill into detail results,
and filter by action, user,
IP address, record
type, or item detail.
One practical limitation to keep
in mind is export
scale and standard.
Exports are limited,
so this tier is best
for focused query rather
than large-scale analysis.
Conceptually, audit logs
help you tell the story
of an incident, and what you
find depends on what you asked.
So it's important to
choose filters that align
to the activity
you expect to see.
Audit Premium, on the other
hand, provides deeper visibility
into user activity, which helps
you investigate sensitive
access, detect
suspicious behavior,
and respond to incident.
Classic example is investigating
email access using the mail send
access activity.
This can show which messages
were accessed, by whom,
and from where within an
activity, bind access logs,
individual emails used, while
sync access logs bulk downloads,
such as when mailbox is
synchronized to Outlook.
There are also practical
considerations, like throttling,
logging pauses after 1,000
buying events per day per
mailbox, and duplicate entries
are filtered automatically
to reduce noise.
You can analyze these events
in the Purview portal
or use PowerShell when you
need advanced filtering,
and exporting to CSV helps
to review access type
and throttling details
into raw audit log.
This is where audit
becomes truly forensic,
helping answer a question,
like whether a departing
employee viewed a sensitive
message, not just whether
something was downloaded.
Exporting audit log to CSV
supports deeper analysis
and helps meet
compliance requirements.
The process starts
by running a search
in the Microsoft Purview portal,
and then selecting Excel
to download up to 50,000
audit records as a CSV file.
For analysis, you can open
the CSV in Excel using Data,
then from Text/CSV, and
use Power Query Editor
to transform the audit
data columns from JSON
into readable columns.
From there, you expand the
properties you care about,
such as IP address,
access type, item detail,
so you can focus on
what's relevant.
This is especially useful when
you need to correlate events
across services or
identify anomalies
such as unusual access
during nonbusiness hours.
Audit retention is a major
part of meeting regulatory
and investigation requirements.
With Audit Premium, you get
custom retention policies
that control how long
audit data is kept.
By default Premium provides a
one-year retention for Exchange,
SharePoint, OneDrive,
and Microsoft Entra ID.
That default policy
can't be changed,
but custom policies get
overwritten for specific needs.
With custom retention
policies you can create
up to 50 policies scoped to
specific users, record types,
or activities, and retain data
from seven days all the way
up to 10 years, although a
10-year retention requires an
add-on license.
One important operational detail
is that retention is determined
at the time data is logged.
So changes apply only to
new data going forward.
From a risk perspective, longer
retention increases resilience
from slow-developing
incidents and helps
in regulated industries
where investigations
or audits may look back years.
Let's recap what we've
covered in this module.
We examined the difference
between Microsoft
Purview Audit Standard
and Microsoft Purview Audit
Premium, how to search
for audited activities using
Microsoft Purview Audit,
and how to implement audit
log searching in practice.
We also discussed how audit log
searches can help investigate
common support issues and
how Audit Premium builds
on the capability
of Audit Standard
to enable deeper investigation.
Finally, we covered how
to create audit log
prevention policies,
and how auditing supports
forensic investigation
of compromised user accounts.
Now, let's see Microsoft Purview
in action in the short demo.
Let's learn how to start
an audit in Purview.
We're currently in
Microsoft Defender,
but let's access
Purview from here.
From the Defender bar, let's
move down to "More Resources".
This gives us access to
link to additional portals,
including the Microsoft
Purview portal.
Let's open it.
Now, when we open
it, it will tell us
that the old compliance
portal is retired.
Let's manually switch
to the new portal.
And here we are in the
Microsoft Purview portal.
The only thing we're going to
do over here is explore how
to start an audit
and basic search.
Let's go into
"Solutions," "Audit."
There's our button,
"Start recording users
and admit activity."
We'll start that.
It will take a moment or
two to start the audit,
and from that point forward,
after we've captured
enough information,
we can start querying and
create cases as necessary.
Let's wrap up with a quick
Learning Path recap.
We've covered how Microsoft
Purview provides compliance
solutions to mitigate threats.
We discussed "Content
Search" as a key feature
within Microsoft Purview
eDiscovery, and also looked
at Microsoft Purview
Audit Solution,
including both Audit
Standard and Audit Premium.
You saw that Audit Standard
is enabled by default
and provides the ability
to log and search
for audited activities, and
that Audit Premium builds
on that foundation by providing
advanced auditing functionality
for deeper investigations and
longer-term requirements.
And this completes our session.
There are many ways to continue
your learning journey.
We encourage you to watch other
videos in Discourse or search
out your next favorite topic on
Microsoft Learn at aka.ms/learn.